Savez-vous à quoi sert un coronographe ?
Pas à observer un virus,
mais un objet beaucoup plus volumineux
dont le diamètre fait presque 110 fois celui de la Terre
et qui est situé à 150 millions de km de nous.
Un coronographe permet d’observer
la couronne du Soleil
et ses magnifiques jets de matière :
on appelle cela une protubérance.
Il a été mis au point par un astronome français,
Bernard Lyot en 1931,
au Pic du Midi de Bigorre dans les Pyrénées.
Il est constitué d’un cache qui se fixe sur un télescope
et qui masque la totalité du disque solaire.
C’est le seul moyen d’observer la couronne du Soleil
Sans lui, le rayonnement est trop important
pour voir ce qui s’y passe
et de toutes les façons, c’est extrêmement dangereux.
On ne regarde jamais le Soleil à l’œil nu
ni même avec des lunettes de soleil,
on peut facilement perdre la vue.
Avant, les astronomes devaient attendre une éclipse totale du Soleil pour observer sa couronne.
Et encore… pendant quelques minutes
et franchement, cela n’arrive pas tous les 4 matins.
Avec le coronographe on peut observer la couronne
du Soleil tous les jours, dès que le ciel est dégagé.
Et profiter de ses magnifiques protubérances,
de véritables « capsules de déconfiné ».
Certaines s’étirent
sur plusieurs centaines de milliers de kilomètres.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Et pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez surtout pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.